well as you all know america is a
horribly racist systemically
ubiquitously racist country where
non-white people
are oppressed everywhere all the time
always the victim of racism over and
over and over again yet somehow for some
reason hate crime hoaxes have never been
more common kind of odd
there's a new hate crime hoax every week
it seems like
not exactly what you would expect you
know inventing hate crime hoaxes
in a racist country is a bit like
bringing your own six-pack
to a keg party it's why do you need to
bring your own if there's enough of it
already on tap
maybe that's because america actually
isn't a racist country who knows you
know in fact maybe it's so
not racist that anyone who wishes to be
the victim
of racism has to invent it for
themselves has to victimize themselves
if you want something done right do it
yourself that's what my dad always said
but i think i didn't i don't think he
had hate crimes in mind exactly when he
said it the great thing
is that hate crime hoaxes are so common
now that there are actual
genres it's kind of like it's you could
almost organize it the way they used to
organize videos at blockbuster if your
kids remember that which you probably
don't but you've got the genres you've
got the um
classic racist graffiti hoax the racist
note hoax the racist message
on a receipt hoax the noose hoax and the
more ambitious
physical uh attack hoaxes which often
involve someone
injuring themselves in order to really
sell it so i thought today we'd go
through
sift through all of these and come up
with a list of the top
five recent hate crime hoaxes we have to
limit it a little bit because there are
so many to choose from
it is and it's difficult to choose even
among the recent ones but i'll give you
my top five listen we all have our
favorites okay i realize that it's
controversial we've all got the ones
that are near and dear to our own hearts
but this these are mine this is what i
consider to be
the top five hate crime hoaxes number
five
this is a recent addition just edged
into the top five a texas a m
university student isaiah martin went
viral got a lot of media coverage
recently after he found racist
notes on his uh windshield of his car
and they said all lives matter
you don't belong here and then uh one of
course was the n word
come to find out huge surprise here um
what nobody except for everybody was
expecting martin
wrote them himself it's a hoax now you
might say this one's a little bit too
cliched a little too
par for the course to warrant a mention
on the list and i get that but but
that's what i like about it if i'm being
honest with you
this hate crime hoax to me is like
comfort food
a hug a kiss and a good hot quaker oats
breakfast
the best school day start you can give
your youngster
it's it's an old classic you know not
trying to
too hard note on the windshield we've
seen it before a little bit of a twist
to make it relevant and current you've
got the all lives matter note added to
it because all lives matter is now a
slur
on par with with the n-word it turns out
and
i like that martin wasn't reinventing
the hoax wheel
okay he wasn't trying to do that is it
safe
is it derivative sure but it was it was
pulled off i think with a with a very
subtle
sort of flare and gusto something that
only the true
hate crime hoax aficionados can pick up
on and appreciate so that's why
he's my number five number four
racist graffiti at the air force academy
outside the dorm rooms of five black
cadets turned out to have been written
by
wait for it one of the black cadets
themselves
the message said go home and there was a
racial slur as well
what pushes this one over the edge and
earns it a spot on the list for me
is that the the hoax hate crime prompted
the superintendent of the school
to give an impassioned speech about how
bad racism is if you can't
treat someone from another race or a
different color skin
with dignity and respect then you need
to get out
listen guys that takes a lot of guts to
say that to come out against
racial slurs to be anti-racial slur
yes that's uh you got to have a backbone
for that because we know of course the
the pro-racial slur camp is so powerful
and influential
so it's very gutsy to stand up like that
and say you know what i'm against racial
slurs
i don't want him don't like him i'm
putting my foot down right now
i don't like racial slurs that takes
guts i'm against crime
and i'm not ashamed to admit it and so i
guess that's why i'm going to put this
in the top five because it gave an
opportunity for that courageous stand by
the superintendent
even though it turns out that the slurs
were written by the slurred
he who was slurred was also the slur
as it turns out now we get to the top
three the competition here is fierce
number three is another recent one
another very recent one a politician in
oregon
jonathan lopez received a deeply
disturbing letter
from an awful dangerous bigot named
jonathan lopez here's what the fake
letter uh
said the fake hate letter it said mr
lopez you're not welcome here and will
never be anything in this community or
state
don't waste your time trying to become
anything in this county we will make you
never win or we will make sure you never
win and your family suffers along with
all the other
effing mexicans in the area sincerely
america
you've got to have very low self-esteem
to talk to yourself that way
i can just imagine lopez in his bathroom
looking in the mirror
talking to himself you'll never win i
hope you suffer
his wife shouts from the other room
honey what are you doing in there
you're not hate criming yourself again
are you we talked about this
even though i put this at number three
the reason it isn't number one
is that the script just didn't come to
life for me it didn't resonate this
isn't what a real racist letter would
sound like
it just wasn't happening for me dawg i
mean i hope you suffer like all the
like all the effing mexicans in the area
sincerely america at the end no that's
what a racist on an episode of law and
order
in 1996 sounds like that's not what a
real racist would sound like
so there's a disappointing lack of
authenticity probably because lopez has
never experienced actual racism
he's never come in contact with a real
racist and that's the irony about all
these hate crime hoaxes is that
you you could tell from the way that
they are so obviously staged that the
people staging them
have just never even encountered an
actual racist in their life
so they have no idea what one would
sound like which is something that you'd
think you'd be grateful for that you've
never encountered that but no lopez
wasn't so he went ahead and
he felt like he was being deprived by
not being a victim of racism so he went
ahead and did it himself
you know the do-it-yourself mentality is
is something at least we can respect
now number two a muslim student jasmine
claimed that she was harassed on the
subway by a drunken group of white men
who shouted donald trump called her a
terrorist
and tried to grab her hijab off her head
of course it was all alive she made it
up the drunk racist white men
didn't exist well let's not say they
didn't exist they didn't exist
exist physically but they did exist in
her heart
and that's what really matters now i'm
just the main thing i'm trying to figure
out
i want to know how she pictured this
scenario when she fabricated it
so they were screaming donald trump was
it supposed to be like in a
celebratory way donald trump whoo
like that or is it a angry and
accusatory donald trump
is it questioning donald trump like they
thought that she was donald trump and
they were mad when they found out she
wasn't you know i don't know who knows
the plot wasn't quite developed as much
as it needed to be some loose ends some
plot holes
i really hope somebody got fired for
that blunder as is so often the case but
the reason i put it at number two on my
top five list
is the motivation the reason she came up
with it apparently she was late coming
home from
a night out she broke her curfew so she
made up this story to her to her dad
so she wouldn't get in trouble now that
is quick thinking i appreciate that and
i remember
you know i tried this once as a teenager
myself we've all done this this is a
this is an old
an old tactic we've all tried i remember
once i came home at 2 a.m
my dad demanded to know where i had been
so i
said that i was accosted by drunken
white men on the subway who grabbed my
hijab
and shouted donald trump and then my dad
pointed out that there are no subways
in my area and that i'm not a muslim
woman
and then he wanted to know why they were
shouting the name of the host of the
apprentice
you do such a disservice when you lie
about things like this
so it didn't exactly work out for me
didn't work out for yasmin it usually
doesn't but she gave it literally
the old college try that's why she's
number two on the list
finally number one the moment we've all
been waiting for
and of course you saw it coming a mile
away i'm not going to surprise you here
i'm not trying to
the top spot has to go to the crowd
favorite
the all-time great the undisputed
champion of hate crime hoaxes
jessie smellet jesse smallettes jessie
smallet
juicy smoothies now i know you might say
it's a little bit too obvious it's like
it's like picking citizen kane
as your greatest film of all time or
something like that but
you've got to pay respects to the
classics that's just how i feel
jesse you know and he he earns his place
as the number one fake hate crime and
i'll tell you why and there's a lesson
here for everyone i think it's an
inspiring lesson
he didn't settle okay a lot of hoaxers
they're gonna claim just that someone
shouted racial slurs
or just that they found a news or just
that they were attacked
uh but smilet he took them all he said i
gotta have
all of that get in my belly okay
he wasn't gonna settle he had the
courage to say no i deserve
a better hate crime this town deserves a
better class
i deserve all the hate crimes give me
all the hate crimes
some might say this is greedy i say this
is the american spirit
this is this is ambition on his part
i get the idea of pissing people off and
so he combined them all into one great
pot and stirred them together and made
himself
a delicious hate crime stew for pure
ambition
um i award jesse smilette the top spot
on the list
i think would-be hoaxers everywhere and
for all time can look up to him
and for good reason he's the he's the
role model he's the guy you're looking
to
he's the high water mark that you're
trying to achieve
in fact you know i think if you made a
mount rushmore of hate crime hoaxers
he's going to be on it
and actually who knows with the way
things are going they may actually put
him
on the real mount rushmore you never
know so those are the top five uh thanks
for watching and
just remember whenever you're planning
your next fake hate crime
stay safe always blame whitey
and most importantly have fun